[Music]
we have a flat bowl here without a flag
it is mounted vertically but it's based
fixed to the ground say a person is
standing some distance away from this
bowl and looking straight at it the line
drawn from the eye of the person to the
distant point where the person is
looking is called line of sight this is
the line of sight since this line is
parallel to the surface we call it the
horizontal line of sight or simply a
horizontal line now if the person is
looking at the top of the pole what
would be the line of sight in this case
the line drawn from the eye to the top
of the pole will be the line of sight we
see that this line of sight makes some
angle with this horizontal line this
angle is called the angle of elevation
the angle of elevation of the top of the
flagpole is simply the angle that this
line of sight makes with the horizontal
line
let me repeat this quickly as it's an
important concept when the person is
looking up the angles formed by this
line of sight with the horizontal line
it's called the angle of elevation note
here that the line of sight is above the
horizontal line what if the person is
looking at the base of the pole what is
the line of sight in this case
the line drawn from the eye to the base
of the pole is the line of sight when
the person is looking at the base in
this case the angle formed between the
line of sight and horizontal is called
the angle of depression yes when a
person is looking down angle formed by
the line of sight with the horizontal
its angle of depression here the line of
sight is below the horizontal so we can
say that when the line of sight is above
the horizontal angle of elevation is
formed and when the line of sight is
below the horizontal angle of depression
is formed here is a simple problem for
you this is to make sure that you've
understood this concept were suppose the
girl is standing in a balcony of a
bungalow and looking straight at a
neighboring building which is taller
than her bungalow but she looks at top
of the building the line of sight is
this one and when she's looking at the
bottom of the building the line of sight
is this one and this is the horizontal
line let us denote the angles that we
see using some letters now here is the
question for you to answer which among
these is the angle of elevation and
which is the angle of depression pause
the video and try to find the answer
angle of elevation is P and is formed
when she's looking up and the angle of
depression is Q which is formed when
she's looking down in the next video we
will solve a few examples based on this
concept
[Music]
you